credo che a tutti capita di pensare che
ne so magari la mattina nei momenti di
dormiveglia o quando si fa un viaggio in
macchina a quale potrebbe essere il
nostro futuro
magari così a immaginarlo come per
scherzo bene questo è quello che
facciamo noi in neuronale spesso anzi
cerchiamo di dargli un metodo pensare a
quello che potrebbe essere il futuro non
visto tanto dai nostri occhi ma da occhi
magari dei nostri figli e dei nostri
nipoti così un qualche anno fa ci è
capitato di pensare appunto a come
potrebbe essere la vita sulla superficie
terrestre seguendo quelli che sono i
macro trend
sappiamo che le citta continuano a
essere sempre più urbanizzate sappiamo
che la popolazione mondiale arriverà
probabilmente a 10 miliardi di persone
nel 2050
consideriamo che nel qualche centinaio
di anni fa in città viveva il 10,5 per
cento della popolazione oggi siamo al 55
per cento della popolazione mondiale
siamo 7 miliardi e mezzo
questo i 7 miliardi e mezzo per il 55
per cento vivono sul 3,5 per cento della
superficie del pianeta
si comincia a pensare che questa densità
sia difficile da gestire
si comincia a vedere già oggi che le
città crescono e si sviluppano diventano
smart è che le zone rurali cioè le zone
periurbane diventano soltanto fornitori
fornitrici di servizi agricoli di
servizi per la produzione di cibo per il
resto sono zone degradate
lo vedete semplicemente uscendo dalle
città trovate le strade di provincia che
sono sui bordi ricche di rifiuti sono
coltivate intensivamente non c'è più
vita non ci sono più boschi non c'è più
ambiente
vuol dire che le zone rurali
peri urbane si staccano dal concetto
della città la città si sviluppa le zone
urbane diventano un puro servizio
indipendentemente dalla qualità della
vita si emarginano si spopolano in
effetti le campagne e le zone rurali
perdono il loro contenuto economico il
loro valore economico il loro valore
ambientale
ci siamo quindi trovati a pensare che un
il mondo non potrebbe essere costituito
da città sparse sul territorio del globo
e circondate o connesse le une tra le
altre da zone degradate questo sia dal
punto di vista dell'aspetto psicologico
sia dal punto di vista ambientale
ci siamo trovati a pensare ea costruire
ea provare a questo punto circa 20 anni
fa una logica diversa dalle zone rurali
periurbane in modo che questi esseri
fornissero non soltanto servizi agricoli
alle città limitrofe ma servizi ma
contribuissero a fornire servizi
ecosistemici e ambientali nel 2050 i 10
miliardi di persone saranno distribuiti
secondo le previsioni di tutti per circa
il 70 80 per cento della popolazione in
città su città che si ingrandiranno ma
che arriveranno dal 3,5 per cento al 4
per cento 45 per cento della superficie
per 10 miliardi di persone
l'ottanta per cento della popolazione
vivrà nelle città come potrà essere
possibile questa densità di popolazione
concentrata in zone limitate dal punto
di vista dello spazio crea ovviamente
delle opportunità la connessione tra
persone la possibilità di avere servizi
per la vita di chiunque informatici di
trasporto eccetera eccetera facili da
raggiungere ma avremo sempre di più se
non facciamo qualcosa zone periurbane
degradate
in effetti le città senza la
collaborazione delle zone urbane
limitrofe delle zone periurbane limite
non possono prosperare lo si vede tutti
i giorni lo si vede tutti i giorni anche
nelle nostre città italiane lo vediamo
per quanto riguarda i rifiuti e la loro
gestione
la densità di popolazione provoca una
densità di scarti e di rifiuti l'energia
che questa densità di popolazione di
utilizzo rappresenta questi carichi di
utilizzo sono estremamente elevati e
concentrati abbiamo un problema di
polluzione le città sono ricche di
elementi inquinanti anche nell'atmosfera
nelle acque le fognature le città hanno
bisogno di cibo cibo che non può essere
prodotto per quella densità di
popolazione dentro le città
e ovvio che questo implica un
cambiamento di paradigma
e questo che ci siamo immaginati lo
abbiamo cominciato a mettere in pratica
negli anni 94 95 su un'idea di non
suocero l'ingegner giuseppe nata
proviamo a vedere come può collaborare
di nuovo la zona rurale periurbana con
le metropoli del futuro
abbiamo preso 500 ettari di pianura
padana e gli abbiamo ritrasformati
rigenerati come questi avrebbero dovuto
essere in epoca preistorica
insomma questo esperimento in 20 anni ha
portato risultati che sono sorprendenti
pure per noi abbiamo ricostruito una
biodiversità che oggi certifica
quell'area come se fosse tornati
indietro di mille anni quindi siamo
tornati in un viaggio del tempo mille
anni indietro bellissima notizia piena
di speranza perché se sappiamo che la
natura messa nelle condizioni di
ricostruire una zona rurale planiziale
in 20 anni ritorna indietro di mille
anni
beh insomma abbiamo un fattore esplosivo
della rigenerazione
rurale questo concetto della natura in
vent'anni ci ha anche insegnato che
molte delle soluzioni che mette in
pratica la natura sono soluzioni che
possono servire anche per il benessere
umano e da lì nascono delle curiosità
dalle curiosità nasce lo studio dallo
studio nasce l'interpretazione corretta
di quei fenomeni e dall interpretazione
corretta di quei fenomeni che cosa nasce
nasce la possibilità di replicarli
cercando di copiare
questa è una innovazione è una
innovazione che noi consideriamo
chiamiamo innovazione dolce
quell'innovazione che non soltanto
innovazione tecnologica ma anche
innovazione culturale la somma delle due
cose da dei risultati appunto
sorprendenti da quell esperimento
noi abbiamo lanciato lo studio di
tecnologie che replicassero quelle
modalità di comportamento quelle
modalità di comportamento naturali sono
diventate tecnologie che possono
contribuire al servizio ecosistemico
ambientale a favore sia dei distretti
urbani sia dei distretti industriali
soprattutto quelli agrifood agrifood che
partono dal campo arrivano alla tavola e
poi tornano indietro al campo secondo un
concetto di economia circolare questo
esperimento appunto durato 25 anni ci ha
fatto capire che le zone di quindi
periurbane diventano zone che forniscono
servizi di alto valore aggiunto
non soltanto agricoli alto valore
aggiunto vuol dire contenuto economico
da questo punto di vista quindi ci siamo
cominciate a spostare verso un concetto
per cui neorurale diventa un produttore
ed ambiente produttore ad ambiente non
come un semplice slogan naturalistico
produttore ed ambiente vuol dire che noi
produciamo ambiente e l'ambiente è un
prodotto che ha un contenuto economico è
valutabile e produce ritorni
sull'investimento
questo è cosa vuol dire essere il
produttore ed ambiente
non è quindi vero ho sempre detto che
attività sostenibili comportino costi
maggiori
anzi una cosa per essere sostenibile dal
punto di vista ambientale deve essere
sostenibile anche dal punto di vista
economico
in questo processo di riportare un
valore economico in queste aree che
erano soltanto agricole e che oggi
restano agricole ma che per fare
agricoltura si spende meno e quindi si
guadagna di più
oltre a questo producono anche delle
efficientamenti ambientali che anch'essi
producono valore economico in zona e di
questo tipo che sono valorizzate anche
dal punto di vista paesaggistico
abbiamo cominciato a pensare di
riportare contenuto economico evita una
cascina come questa che è una volta
ospitava circa 150 famiglie
lo diciamo per stare bassi 150 persone
oggi non occupa più nessuno
ma cosa può occupare può occupare nuove
professionalità di persone che non sono
di per sé delle persone dedite
all'agricoltura non sono dei rurali ma
sono dei nuovi rurali e da qui nasce il
nome neorurale in quanto noi riportiamo
competenze diverse in zone rurali dove
queste competenze diverse possono essere
valorizzate nel campo
dicevo prima agrifood nel concetto
appunto from farm to fork e back to farm
and gain secondo uno slogan inglese
questi modelli di sostenibilità per
essere appunto sostenibili devono
esserlo non soltanto dal punto di vista
ambientale ma devono anche esserlo dal
punto di vista economico e di ritorno
sugli investimenti per farlo
uno degli elementi fondamentali è
sicuramente l'innovazione il fattore
abilitante e l'innovazione sia
tecnologica che culturale
come dicevo poc'anzi e deve essere
basata sul fatto che noi riportiamo
contenuto economico e vita
queste zone che altrimenti sarebbero
emarginate il modello stesso può essere
scalato ed esportato in altre latitudini
con altri modi di vivere secondo
attitudini anche umane diverse
già ci sono degli esempi nel mondo
alcuni anche nostri che noi applichiamo
stiamo applicando in nord america e in
africa
ovviamente per portare secondo
condizioni di vita diverse latitudini
diverse
lo stesso concetto sul mercato ecco
questo è ciò che rappresenta la nostra
iniziativa rendere zone normalmente
emarginate o che stanno per essere
emarginate nel mondo di nuovo attraenti
per quanto riguarda uno sviluppo
economico e sostenibile sostenibili
ambientalmente sostenibile
economicamente e finanziariamente come
dicevamo prima
questo permette alle città del futuro di
essere collegate le une alle altre
attraverso soluzioni di continuità che
risolvano le criticità di resilienza
delle città ci piacerebbe che tutto
questo concetto però diventasse un
concetto basato sulla responsabilità la
responsabilità della gente fa sì che il
pianeta rimanga di qualità perché si è
data alla proprietà terriera a singoli
proprietari fin dall'epoca dei romani
perché ciò che è di proprietà di un
singolo viene mantenuto ciò che non è
proprietà di nessuno
come vediamo chiaramente ovunque non
viene curato ma è l'unico pianeta che
abbiamo è il più grande pianeta che
abbiamo
forse bisognerebbe cominciarlo a
considerare come una casa nostra non di
altri